all right we are now live
it looks like for the hegel party
this is not the first of our eagle purse
in the past
uh we've we've done some when we hit i
think
200 videos when we got into the spirit
section so this is uh one definitely
to celebrate and um the official reason
for this celebration is that we're
moving at last
from the spirit section of the work the
longest
section of the phenomenology so we've
gotten this far into the book
and we're moving into the religions
section which
is um a good portion
of it but much smaller than spirit say
it's this this amount
and then you might say well what about
the rest of the book well there's
absolute knowing which is very short and
then there's
all of miller's notes as well so
um this is this is definitely for me
something to celebrate
let me see if i can brighten there we go
brighten this up a little bit
um i went in
and took a look at the dates
on the videos and the first video in
this series was from
late february 2004
which means that we have been
you know working away at this for almost
seven years
you know i wrote a long time ago in the
half hour hegel blog for some reason i
thought it would take me two or three
years
and even if i had stayed like completely
on track
and got six videos done per month i
think it still would have taken me you
know five to six years
we have probably if i stay on track a
num
another year or so of the
the project and then you know i'll start
thinking about what i'm going to do next
i've already done the
sort of half hour thing for epictetus
discourses
i'm thinking about doing it when i've
got the available time for
rene descartes meditations using both
the latin
the original latin text the french
translation
a lot of people don't realize that you
know descartes didn't write the
meditations in french he had it
translated into french
before him and then an english
translation
um and then you know i might take on
another big book
down the line um we'll see you know it's
kind of it's
you know this is a great test of concept
right doing this book took
quite a long time actually still taking
quite a long time
so i thought it would be cool to uh
take a sunday uh afternoon and spend
maybe you know we'll see how much time
when people start asking questions
or making comments to respond to we'll
see how long this lasts maybe an hour or
so of of chit chat back and forth
i do want to say a few things about the
project and
about why the religion section
is important so
let's start with the the second part
right and then i can tell you about the
project in in just a bit
so the religion section is
the the the last of the big
chunks right we had the
consciousness self-consciousness those
are fairly
short compared to spirit
and reason which are much longer much
more involved a lot more going
on there and then we have this religion
section you might say well
what's that doing there why why are we
now talking about
religion and hegel has brought up
religion at different points
in the work and that's part of what he's
going to talk about in the very first
paragraphs the introductory
section he's going to say listen we have
talked about religion you know the
unhappy consciousness is about trying to
reach god and
not being able to do so um there's
religion
coming up the religion of the underworld
and you know the laws of the gods
and uh that sort of stuff in the whole
antiquity business
in the early spirit section and there's
you know religion in the the discussion
about
um faith right so that's also
pretty important too
and um yeah oh we did talk about
religion
now we're going to look at it
thematically
and he says a few things in there that
are kind of interesting
that i'm not going to like try to unpack
in great detail because that's happening
in the commentary
videos but i will point this out he
talks about
in that that introduction to the
religion section the pre
the three of the four sorry previous
um developments these threads
of consciousness self-consciousness
reason and spirit
together in this phenomenon
of religion and it's spirit that's
coming together and
self you know self-consciousness looking
for its
looking for its um
you could say objective reality in
relation to
another something going back to the
self-consciousness section it's looking
for recognition
so all of these things are being brought
together
now and re-worked in
in some way in the religion section now
when you read through the the bits and
pieces of it you
might be like well i don't i don't
actually see that happening and i think
that's a that's a valid complaint
actually quite quite frankly um the
other thing that you might say well
why why this religion section why is
this coming up here um
hegel thought that religion is
basically you know a way in which
human human beings are developing
consciousness
throughout their history in relation to
something
divine something absolute something
eternal not realizing that they're
they're projecting that outside of
themselves
and that religion is essentially sort of
like philosophy
but in what he calls picture language um
or you know in in representation for
stella
hegel's not the only person to say this
by the way i mean you can see something
kind of similar
coming up in earlier thinkers uh
including avaros i would say cicero if
you look at
his discussion in on the nature of the
gods book three
um there's a few other authors who are
gonna say listen religion
is like you know religion is there's a
lot of interesting stuff there if we
strip away all the superstition and and
you know kind of
goofy stuff and we look at what what's
going on in in the development of of
religion
um it's like philosophy but it's not
it's not quite philosophy yet so it's
for people who are smart but not smart
enough for philosophy
is that hegel's position i would say yes
in a way
except that hegel thinks that there has
to be this ongoing
development taking place right um
and so as you could say that
in in a certain way philosophy
in in hegel's sense becomes available
through the development of human beings
and
you know that that that sometimes
includes what was there in past
philosophy
but you know it's like the big guns have
come out now and and
and it's happened in part for hegel
through
this walk through religion and
particularly through
greek religion and through revealed
religion
the last of which is going to be
christianity i mean i guess the last
other thing i want to say about hegel is
hegel is really unorthodox you know he
is not
he's a lutheran he's not an orthodox
lutheran um stanley rosen
in his his book on hegel and i'm not
remembering the exact name
he's considering the issue of whether
hegel's an orthodox christian or not
and he says hegel uh belongs to a church
a church of one
name it's the church uh that includes
hegel
and i think i think that's right um and
so
you don't you don't want to go to hegel
for like
christian doctrine or something the way
you might go to augustine
um but it's it's worth it's worth
checking out there's a lot of
interesting stuff going on there
you know i i wanted to write my
dissertation originally on hegel and the
matter of religion i did a few
early publications when i was you know a
grad student on that
um his lectures on the philosophy of
religion are very interesting
if you if you like this section i would
check those out because there's a lot
more
substantive discussion of religion in in
those
um so that's probably enough about hagel
and religion i see a lot of comments
already
piling up um let me
say something about the project so how
did the project get started
you know when i first started getting on
youtube
i was uploading class videos and then
people were like hey can you do videos
on this can you do videos
on that um hey there's there's bruce hey
thanks thanks thanks bruce
always happy to see you there um bruce
is a long time
in like interlocutor of of mine
i think he's been here really since the
start of the project
and there are quite a few people who
have been with me the entire way which
is quite cool
so anyway people were saying can you do
videos on on people
and i said okay let's look at what the
number
one requests are and when i started
going through my
videos and sort of tabulating it it was
jean-paul sartre martin heidegger
you know george william friedrich hagel
and
weirdly enough herbert marcuza and i was
like well
all right i can i can do sart and
heidegger
by like focusing on existentialism i've
gotten you know really interested in
that again
lately i was interested in my teens and
twenties and then kind of let it slide
let me go back to that so i started a
whole sequence
on existentialism and what i would do
there is i would take a book like
nietzsche's birth of tragedy
and devote like four one-hour lectures
to it right and that was that was
adequate
and then i started thinking okay what
can i do for hegel why don't i go
through
since it's this is the book everybody
requests right
um why don't i go through and work on
on this and i was like can i do this
kind of big picture
thing i don't i don't think i can do
justice to
to hegel and the phenomenology by trying
to do that
so does that mean i have to go down to
like the paragraph
level that's going to be a lot of work
and then i was like
ah the hell with it let's try it out and
i
don't think i i don't know where my
numbers came from
about thinking about how i was gonna do
this and it was it wasn't gonna take
quite so long
but i um you know i started doing it and
you know the early videos obviously i
wasn't using my my voice recorder
that i've got here so the sound quality
is not quite so good
and i was using a flip cam instead of my
my nice gopro so the video quality
was not as as good but it works people
got into it they were able to
benefit from it and i just started you
know experimenting around with like well
you know i guess you know i didn't even
really think a lot of these things
through i was like okay so we've got a
black background that's nice there's me
there's hegel
there's the description and then we we
got through the preface and i was like
oh
we can't do the same background right we
got to change it up let's do white okay
and then i video recorded with me be you
know
be in front of this bamboo thing i think
right and then we got into sense
certainty and and i
and i was like well the consciousness
section all right we'll make that this
color and then we start
i came up with a whole color scheme for
it
and you know it started going on created
a patreon
um which which a lot of people have
contributed to which is great because
the videos take a lot of time out of my
my
other pursuits that would be otherwise
you know more
uh uh you know earning an income right
and um you know people have been
watching these and benefiting from them
i actually should go through and look at
the statistics again i haven't done that
for a long time
but um i'm sure there's been like not
millions of views necessarily of these
videos but at least hundreds of
thousands of views
of them and um
you know the bulk of the comments are
pretty positive there's people asking
questions sometimes
every once in a while you get somebody
who's like uh you suck man you know but
but for the most part it's like oh this
is really
nice and and helpful and so
i've got to meet a lot of uh really
great people over
over time through doing these videos
some of them
you know hegelians most of them not many
of them students
bruce who i mentioned earlier is a great
example
um there's been quite a few other people
who have been quite interested
in what's going on with hegel and and
you know we've talked about it and so
i've benefited considerably myself
from you know so i put the videos out
and those benefit other people and i
benefited from from people's engagements
with me about it as well um the last
thing i'll say about the project
other than you know i'm going to
continue seeing this through obviously
is i'm not a hegelian you know i'm i'm a
philosophical eclectic
and it's interesting because when i do
videos on nietzsche people think i'm a
nietzschean if i do videos on
the stoics they think i'm a stoic you
know if i do videos on
on uh aristotelianism they think like
i'm a hardcore
aristotelianism i think that there's you
know there's stuff that's valuable
in all of these approaches and
you know i think this is this is
definitely a book that deserves
i don't want to say more love but
definitely more more attention
and i'm happy to have contributed to
doing it
there are better you know there are way
better hegel scholars out there than
me i'm you know he's not like
my main focus of all of my research
but none of them wanted to do this so
you know i'm the one who who is willing
to put in the time
and uh i did it in part also to try to
you know not just
be able to provide something for for
other people
but also to try to encourage other
people to do similar
work now i know there's a question up
here about about
marx so let me jump into questions and
comments um julio patino says capital by
karl marx
so i don't have to do any of marks right
because david harvey who is
you know a high caliber marx scholar
he's got videos doing a similar sort of
thing going through
marks and doing so you know line by line
very attentively explaining what's going
on so that's cool because
i don't think i'd be up to doing um
carpental that would take me forever
and you know same thing with other
thinkers like you know people are like
why don't you do this on sarts being in
nothingness
or schopenhauer's world you know the the
will
the world is will and representation i'm
still a little bit sick so i'm a little
bit
out of it um ideally somebody else would
do those
right you know somebody who's who's like
a full-time
schopenhauer scholar full-time sart
uh researcher it would be cool to get
them to do that
it doesn't all have to be me i'm you
know i should stick to the text that i'm
really
good at like you know one of the other
ones i was thinking about doing was
saint anselm's pro slogan going through
it line by line
you know what's what's actually going on
here looking at the latin
that wouldn't take anywhere near as long
as obviously
hegel's phenomenology but
you know i think that there i would like
to see other people
applying this half hour thing and it
turns out half hour is just about enough
you know it's the education experts are
always like oh
you know it can't be more than five
minutes people are gonna you know lose
patience and
they're not gonna be able to concentrate
that turns out to be complete [ __ ]
and you know who knows what was found in
but that's completely wrong
an hour probably too long half an hour
is a good
good thing for this kind of intensive
commentary
all right um let's see
tyson says yay descartes happy hagel day
thanks yeah descartes i'm you know again
i'm not a cartesian but i love teaching
descartes and reading descartes
that's funny because um there was there
was a comment recently
somebody posted about like uh you know
french
french writers are all you know kind of
show-offs and
heart it's hard to read their stuff it's
complex and i was like man you haven't
read a lot of french writing you know
read descartes
you know he's pretty straightforward in
the discourse or in his letters or stuff
like that that that sort of like
show-offiness that's from like the 1940s
onward
um previous stuff is pretty pretty
straightforward
all right um dammit albert says humanity
students that are too terrified of
hegel's impenetrable
pros thanks for this um
hegel's not a great writer um
i'm laughing because i'm remembering one
of my
uh philosophy professors from when i was
an undergraduate who was a german guy
and he was like you know he grew up
during world war ii
and then emigrated to to the united
states
and he would always joke that he
kept hegel and i don't know whether it
was the logic uh
or which logic or the you know
philosophy of right or the phenomenology
on his on his bed stand and whenever he
found himself
insomniac he would read some hegel and
by the end of the paragraph
he would be ready to go to sleep and you
know that's a little bit too far to the
extreme but yeah hegel's
hegel's writing is pretty dense and it
often doesn't get better when you go to
the german and look at the german
um i you know i haven't read hip elites
french translation for
for quite a while but i will say this
that um hippolyte actually
from what i remember his french
translation
manages to be somehow more clear than
hegel's own german it's probably also
because hippolyte
has like it's copiously annotated with
with footnotes
um you know and so i i remember you know
photo actually i photocopied the two
volumes of it my mentor had it in
his office and i was like hey man can i
can i photocopy these because he'd also
written his own marginalia
in the side and and uh i thought that
was kind of
important at the time and i i read
through it um and i
enjoyed it all right so benjamin says
biggest event of the day
forget the super bowl um i mean i'm just
gonna like check the stance on the super
bowl because obviously i don't have a
dog in that fight anymore
other than wanting to see uh brady lose
you know
um like like most of the country i think
um
wherever he happens to be and it's not
even because the buccaneers beat the
packers
you know i just i don't like the guy um
and patrick mahomes you know you can
kind of root for him and root for the
the chiefs um it would have been nice to
have like a repeat of super bowl
one with the packers and the chiefs
playing
but you know that was not in the cards
so
yeah let's see if i missed anything
chris has a funny
joke are your consciousness is actually
here only a negative actuality
um all right let's see what else we have
here
another joke by spook spookfester fairly
short aka the length of an average
fiction
book um yeah you mean the phenomenology
of spirit when i first read that as it
was scrolling i was like ah
he's trying to pull a fast one and say
this is a book of fiction
and really it is i mean there's no such
thing
as world spirit doing all the things
that hegel's saying that it's doing
in any sort of literal sense but yeah we
could i guess we could read
you know read it and say what are we
corresponding to figuratively
here um by the way speaking of fiction
after i get done with this
i am gonna go off and be you know the
biggest [ __ ] i can possibly be
uh [ __ ] of course meaning being a
big fan of philip k
dick who i'm doing um this month for the
worlds of speculative fiction
and so once i get done with this and
then like probably
decompress a little bit i'm going
downstairs into
the room where the cat lives and and
spends most of her time and it used to
be the kids bedroom but now she's taking
it over
and that's where i do some of my my
filming so
i'm going to be filming today
the video that's going to premiere next
saturday for the worlds of speculative
fiction
series on philip k dick's novels that
have to do with insanity and space
colonization
like um you know maze of death three
stigmata of palmer eldritch
um oh um what am i blanking on
um all right i can't can't remember them
right off hand but i'll be talking about
those after i get off of here and
i'm having a special guest come in my
friend and collaborator
michael gomez who is a psychologist
and trains other psychologists he's
going to be talking about some of these
psychiatric diagnoses that dick is
throwing around
so hegel is not somebody who dick talks
about a lot by the way
he actually does talk about kant quite a
bit believe it or not
um all right uh camille says half our
hegel will be in the history books as
one of the biggest projects in our
internet era
well we'll see i mean it's it's not
getting a lot of
traction or notoriety in even like the
public philosophy
domain of the the internet i think a lot
of people don't know about it
um it's kind of interesting because it's
been going on now seven years right
so i probably should like send out some
press releases
or things like that about um
about the project if i want to get
people interested in it
um it's it's a labor of love i'll tell
you that
um and it's one that i've i've invested
a lot of
time and thought into so if there's if
there's like
280 something videos right now
each of them half an hour so that's 140
hours
you know each hour of video footage is
probably
10 hours of my work so
yeah it's like 1400 hours of work
that i've been that i've been doing so
all right uh dan the man says wish i
wasn't at work on a short break
uh you know the good thing about this is
you know you can always watch it
afterwards right
um gutter grown is saying
number one mapping the human genome go
to the number two mapping the hegel
i i don't know that it's that's it's
quite that momentous but you know
that's it's good uh damn it are you
familiar with the work of islamic golden
age thinkers yeah i'm familiar but not
an expert in it you know
uh oh here's a good question from
spookfest does religion the section
suffer from eurocentrism yeah definitely
um
and it not only suffers from
eurocentrism
it suffers from germanol lutheran
centrism
as well um hegel you know hegel thinks
that
europe is and he includes you know parts
of the mediterranean
is really where like the whole the whole
thing is is happening you know and
this is a problem with his with his view
on history
um i think sort of like how aristotle
with his views on women
which are pretty boneheaded if you were
to bring aristotle into our present
get him past the culture shock that he'd
incur
and then start having him interact with
you know
women students and professors and all
that he'd rapidly revise
his his views on things i think hegel
probably
given the opportunity would would take
back some of the things that he said
about
about history but uh he can't do that
because he's dead
uh and he's been you know gone since
the 1840s so you know more than 100 and
more than 160 years
it is eurocentric i i don't think that
means that
we automatically you know reject it or
set it aside but we have to
contextualize you know
like when hegel says that africa has no
history obviously that's wrong
you know and and he could have even
figured out that that was wrong in his
day but but he didn't
and so we have to figure out what are we
going to do with that um
all right uh marlon henry curse william
desmond has books on hegel's religiosity
too sort of a whole
ton of other people you know uh
falkenheim
you know i think i've actually still got
the book that i never returned to the
siu library
about the religious dimension of hegel's
thought on my shelves somewhere
there's lots of people who've talked
about about that yeah
um all right let me see
just skipped a little bit
uh julian says thank you for doing this
it's been a great tool for me and my
independent study of hegel what
is the biggest pitfall for beginners in
reading and making sense of hegel
that's a good question oh uh i think
so my sort of like gut response
is thinking that you have to
understand everything in a
paragraph or a section before moving on
to the next one
i think that if you do that you get
stuck and you'll like
really never finish the book um
i think it's okay to read things and
then not
fully understand what's going on and
sort of like pick it up the next reading
or with what's being said later on that
and that not just for hegel
but for for philosophers in general you
know i think the first reading through
should be sort of like you know dodging
things here and there and just just
trying to get yourself through it you
know
and that's okay that's normal i would
say the second biggest
issue is well there's two other really
big issues
thinking that hegel works by uh thesis
antithesis synthesis
i mean there are sometimes so you look
at the way the sections are set up right
he does like threes
so in reason right you've got
observing reason uh and then the
actualization of rational
self-consciousness and individuality
and each of those big sections is
divided into three sections
but that doesn't mean that it's actually
thesis antithesis synthesis
that's that's a different thing than
they call it hegelian dialectic
they should call that uh [ __ ]
hegelian dialectic you know
what's what's actually going on is
usually a lot more complicated every
once in a while it will actually
coincide with that
but that's not the the key to unlocking
hegel and then of course the third thing
is
don't believe the [ __ ] about the
master slave dialectic is the most
important thing in hegel and
everything else centers around that you
could say the master slave dialectic is
a very crude primitive thing happening
early on in the
self-consciousness section the other
parts of which our attempts to go past
that and introduce
new and important content and the
recognition or lack of recognition
that's happening
and the development on the part of the
slave those are just
motifs they are not the essence of what
hegel's up to
so i think those those could be helpful
um jake says am i doing anything special
for a hundred thousand
hundred thousand views that i can talk
about oh some subscriptions yeah
uh probably i'll probably do another
thing like this you know
um my my daughter has been eagerly
awaiting for me to get to 100
000 views because something special
happens in youtube world
like you can you get a special little
thing on your channel
or something like that um i don't
actually know but we're getting close
i i should take a look um where
are we in uh
terms of views 97
400 subscribers is what it says
in the little thing so um yeah we're
getting pretty close
i imagine we'll we might pass it up in
in march you know at the current rates
that we're going in
um so yeah
uh am i going to do something special i
i got to i got to think about it
if anybody has any good suggestions i'd
be open to hearing them
luke and lazy i know you're not a
hegelian but what hegelian ideas do you
most agree with or like so one thing i
really really love about hegel is the
insistence
that ideas if you want to evaluate an
idea and understand an idea it's got to
be made
actual it's got to be made viewer click
or real right
and then what always ends up happening
is just like when you plan stuff right
oh we're gonna have
the best family reunion ever we've got
all the plans made
things never turn out quite like that
you have to see what what the essence of
the thing is
in its actuality not just in your
imagination
not just in potentiality in how it
actually
shows itself and you know hegel for the
showing it's not just that we're passive
observers like just sitting there
watching it it's instead we
are also transformed in the process i
think he's completely right about that
um that's a insight he shares with you
know american pragmatists with maurice
blondell
with um you know certain construals of
of aristotle
you know it's it's kind of a good way to
make sense of of things
what else i like the idea that
i think he's right human consciousness
has developed through
our our history the history turns out to
be more complex than he
originally framed it and it's more
global than he he framed it there's that
eurocentric
idea again but i think he's right that
you know
and this is an idea by the way that
again not totally unique to
hegel aristotle even noted differences
in
how you know drama how dialogue was
being written back in his own time he's
like back in the old days
uh the the people spoke like statesmen
now they speak like rhetors so he's
noticing
temporal succession and trying to trace
out uh
you know why that would be the case
rousseau's another great example too you
know
um human human beings this the
sentiments the very emotional capacities
that we have
developed over time they're not just
like hardwired into our dna
right so
all right um
jake asked what is special about the
religion section in the historical
context of philosophy of religion if
we're talking about like contemporary
analytic philosophy of religion
no there's no no interest in hegel at
all
um if we're talking about philosophy
religion more broadly i mean it's a
developmental account of
of religion which is probably wrong uh
most developmental accounts of religion
whatever religion you've got is like you
know the highest development and all the
other stuff are just
you know processes along the way i don't
i don't really
care for those sorts of accounts i think
a more pluralistic account is better
um you know i i i don't really
know that much in contemporary
continental philosophy of religion but i
don't see an awful lot of reference to
hegel as such you see more reference to
kierkegaard
um which is not surprising um
hey you know when i teach philosophy of
religion i do so from a comparative
perspective and so like when i talk
about
you know the arguments for existence for
god which don't really come up in the
phenomenology but do
in the lectures on the philosophy of
religion i talk about what the
motivation
for having these arguments is and hegel
has some really interesting discussion
of that he says they're not supposed to
prove anything
you know that's not the way people do
religion that's not the way people
convert or anything like that they're
supposed to help you understand what god
is
you know and what our relation to god is
so it all it all depends on how you how
you look at it
um
let's see here pose apprentice do you
think friedrich nietzsche's birth of
tragedy was influenced by hegel's
phenomenology
no i think it was influenced by hegel
but
it's important to remember that the
phenomenology was not really widely read
by um people until the 20th century
then then it suddenly assumed a massive
importance
before that it was more like the you
know the two logics the science of logic
and the
encyclopedia logic and of course
philosophy of right that people were
paying more attention to
nietzsche tells us that the birth of
tragedy is too hegelian so presumably
he you know it would why wouldn't he be
influenced by
the most influential thinker of the time
at his time you know it was going to be
some influence
so um
all right let's see marianne henry says
nobody's done a half hour on
maurice blondell nobody's done a half
hour on on
hardly anybody uh you know
this whole youtube thing is kind of new
at the time that i was starting this um
so it was sort of a landmark for youtube
right there was there was youtube
uh that people were getting into in the
uh
in the early 2000s and then around i
think
it's 2011 um
an important transition was made first
like if you didn't have an institutional
account
you could only do videos that were like
10 minutes long and then it was
15 minutes and then it was 20 minutes
and then they opened it up to
anything so that was was an important
transition the half hour hegel project
starts
three years into that that transition
time
um we're now 10 years down that line
and it's not that surprising that there
aren't that many
people doing this i mean first of all
you have to actually
if you're doing something in a foreign
language you got to be able to read that
foreign language
well because you're giving you know
sort of an in-depth thing into it you've
got to be willing to invest the time
into something that is not going to be
like commercially viable
you know the half-hour hagel patreon
project i'm glad it's there
uh and i'm very grateful for all the
people who have contributed to it
through
through the years um it doesn't
you know would i be making minimum wage
given the amount of time that i put in
for
the videos um yeah probably you know
probably it depends you know on how many
people are doing it at the time but it's
not
it's not it's not something that most
academics are gonna say yeah man
i'm gonna devote a number of hours each
month to doing like
william james's varieties of religious
experience half an hour at a time really
close attention to the text you know
so john asked what's my stance on
religion
i mean that's that's too vague to even
answer um
i don't know what i would say to that
molecule said i saw you comment that the
religion section of the phenomenology
used to be your favorite why was that
because i was like super into philosophy
of religion at the time and i thought it
was you know a lot of cool stuff going
on there in hegel's
um phenomenology so
yeah um
let's see chris says what main takeaways
do you hope
we your hegelian ducklings get from your
series apart from just the encouragement
to get through the phenomenology um
that's a good question i mean i hope you
also get encouragement to read hegel for
yourself
i know that there are like hegel reading
groups that have organized and are using
this as a resource but presumably a lot
of the
a lot of the discussion that they're
having is not well dr sandler says or
you know
but it's more like well hegel's saying
this and here's some people over on
on the side who have some some useful
ideas about it what are we going to do
with this text right now
and i'll mention i'll do a little bit of
storytelling here
we did a hegel reading group
twice in in my graduate
school and i was a part of it
and what we would do is we would get
together at like a bar
or a cafe and
sometimes people's houses and we would
um each person would be like assigned a
section
to to summarize and lead us through
and i did
parts of the religion section and i did
the master slave dialectic
um because i was like you know one of
the hangel guys in the in the department
at the time
and you know we would get together and
usually you know we'd be drinking
and i would you know back then i was i
was
living in a trailer park south of town
in carbondale and riding around on my
bike
um so i didn't have a car and you know
it was a very hard drinking department
and i remember there was like a there
was what we call the philosophy house
on the uh the uh north end of town in in
carbondale i might be mixing things up i
think i was on the south side and they
were on the north side
and um you know it was a bunch of
philosophy
guys who lived there and so they partied
a lot
and we would go there and um there was a
liquor store like
just two blocks from there so that's
where everybody would be before that
buying their drinks and i would i would
uh buy
you know like a 40 ouncer of
mgd uh draft and um
you know because it was super cheap it's
like a buck something and then walk over
to the philosophy house
and um we would do philosophy and drink
some beer or
people drink liquor or whatever and
smoked a lot too you know
and had a good time discussing it and i
think that
that's part of it too you know people
are having these groups
people are continuing these discussions
um what else should people
get from the series um
i mean ideally there the series is just
there to provide you with some
some uh clarification um
you don't have to feel like you have to
watch every single one you know
i i think they can be used kind of in a
targeted way like you get to pair
you know you're reading around your you
know the paragraph 492 and you're like
what the hell is going on here well
that's the time maybe to go to the
series and see what what somebody else
has to say about it and some of the time
i might say what the hell's going on
here
right um
hitchcock i imagine hegel was much more
fun to talk to
than to read you know his lectures are
pretty straightforward
um compared to like the phenomenology
but that's his students
helping out with that right
he seems to have been a i mean they talk
about him being melancholic
but he seems to have been a pretty
decent guy um and and i think i would
have enjoyed like sitting down and
chatting with the guy
myself and probably a lot of you would
as well
um let's see
could you please explain how you managed
to learn german french greek and still
have read this much well i'm 50 years
old
you know so i've i've lived a long time
probably twice as long as some of the
people who are
are commenting here um i was at an
advantage when it comes to french
in that my my mother's family is french
canadian
and my mother even though she was a
fourth generation immigrant
grew up speaking french at home because
her mom was from quebec you know
and my grandfather you know he spoke
french before english as well
even though he was a third generation
immigrant so
i grew up in the generation i'm one of
the older people in my generation
in the family the lamries family and
i grew up hearing all the old people
speaking french
admitted you know of course you know
canadian french not parisian french
and um you know you just pick up some of
that you don't actually like learn any
grammar or anything but you learn a
little bit of vocabulary and you learn
some of the affective nuances and some
of the really basic words
um and then my mom made me take french
when i was in eighth grade
and when i was in 10th grade in high
school and and you know
i i didn't want to like learn it but i
picked up some stuff
in the process i was you know
she made me learn it because i should
learn some proper grammar
and i screwed around in class and got by
on the french that i already knew you
know
and then when i was in college i got
thrown into this french house
uh they were trying these language
suites and they had like a native
language speaker
and then you know other people who were
like supposed to be learning the
language and they found out that i
learned french so they threw me in there
and i was like well i get my own room so
that's awesome i'll do that and we had
to take a class
in french and the textbook itself was in
french and so i finally like buckled
down and i was like yeah i'm gonna learn
french
and so i did you know and then um when i
was in uh
you know then i traveled to quebec and
you know met up with some of my
relatives and hung out in montreal
and went to europe and um
came back to you know go to grad school
and just kept on with
the french right so that that was good
all the old people are dead now so
there's not a lot of people in my family
to talk french with
which is kind of a sad thing but that's
life
the german um you know i began
learning some rudiments of german when i
was in elementary school
but you know in sort of a half-assed way
of course
uh because you know wisconsin and the
part of wisconsin i lived in you were
probably either german or welsh if you
lived in the
village of wales and so you know we'd
have people who'd
like go to germany and exchange things
and come back and you know
teach a little bit and then i i never
really buckled down with it until
i got um well i lived in germany as a
soldier right and so i learned some
basic german
enough to get by but never like studied
the language and then you know there are
people in the german house and i'd chit
chat with them
uh but it was sort of like you know
drinking and eating german and then
i got myself a teach yourself german
book from my uncle hubert's library
turned out it was from
1896 and so i learned you know
some old german script and stuff like
that and
which is very useful when i was reading
hegel because the the
hegel german the german hegel book that
i had was the second
edition copy of the phenomenology which
was in the old frock tour
and i just you know kept up with it and
then you know i'll start reading stuff
in the language and
going to like stompish and chit chatting
with people and
you know i went over to back to germany
um and
and so you know that was good uh greek i
learned in a more formal way taking
classes
um latin i kind of learned on my own but
i had the advantage of having had some
baby latin and in sixth and seventh
grade because i went to a private middle
school
you know where you were either rich or
smart and they had latin class there
and we didn't go that far but um and
then later on i was able to use that
basis and
get my latin up to decent par you know
all right um
let's see here uh jose is asking a
philip k dick question so he's obviously
a [ __ ] too
uh how about valace so valas
i talked about in another dick thing
when i talked about philip k dick's
alternative america
i may mention valas but i probably will
not look at it a thematic way in this
one
all right chris says
my best friend and i started reading
this hegel together in september
just because we heard it was hard to
read he gave up her way through the
introduction
but i'm almost at the end of spirit in
joking retaliation for abandoning me i
wrote an eight-page paper on his
development as a consciousness using
dense hegelian language as i could
muster for his most recent birthday that
is awesome that's
that's really funny that's the sort of
crap that we would pull in graduate
school
you know when we had more time on our
hands and and
probably more energy and we like to you
know zing each other
that is a really great story all right
um
luke and lazy what do you think of
people identifying as hegelia nietzsche
and etc as it is a sign of a second-rate
mind
wholly follow someone else's philosophy
i mean not necessarily so
i mean there are some people who are
convinced that like you know hegel
fundamentally had it right
and there's hegelian in the sense of
like okay i'm a follower of hegel and
then there's like i'm a i'm a researcher
on hegel and that's what i do my most
work on
um you know
you can also go through phases i i went
through many phases where i was you know
convinced that somebody
finally had the the right thing
including the nietzschean phase right
and that was probably one of my longer
phases um
not least because it gave me sort of a
good you know
explanation for why it's okay to be a
jerk which i was doing at the time
and not just a jerk but an elitist jerk
um
[Music]
so and no i don't think it necessarily
but tokens having a second class
um second-rate mind um
sometimes it can be quite useful and
you know sometimes we have some really
great
expositors of
these these other these other thinkers
right
but you know i i kind of get where
you're going there are a lot of people
kind of glom
on to philosophers and
use them you know hegel's susceptible to
that nietzsche
marx duluz is another big one today
um and they're like oh as a blah blah
you know actually stoicism too is a
great example i run into all these
people
who are like i'm a stoic and you know i
know all about stoicism and it turns out
that
me not a stoic has actually
forgotten more than the stoicism that
they claim to
to uh to know in part because i spent a
lot of time
studying it right
maybe there should be some some line
that you have to cross
before you get to label yourself as a
dash
i-a-n or ite or something like that
um audlen can i recommend any philosophy
of music
it's not really an area that i i um i
know
very well so there's not much for me to
say
about that unfortunately um
it just looks like it just scrolled a
little bit
let's see what we got here
uh the now church says hegel was
eurocentric but his version of
christianity
is way better than the mainstream that
depends on what the mainstream is where
you are
i guess you know um eb when hegel claims
the knight of black cows isn't he's
still seeing black cows in the night
rather than just absolute darkness
he seems to be able to delineate the
cow's form and content he's doing so
thinking about it but i mean he could
just be like
bumping into them right you've all been
on camping trips i imagine when it's
like pitch black
right golden apples excited to be here
for the hegel party thanks for putting
this together glad that you
you enjoy that um
richard gallant says thanks for the work
you're very welcome
um the now church says just celebrated
bob marley yesterday hegel today and you
brought up philip k
dick that's great um spook
spook fester how do you feel about hegel
using reconciliation to bring up god and
then religion
to me it's one of the weirdest arguments
he makes well it's not an argument
so if if you start by saying it's
something different a rational account
rather than an
argument you'll you'll find it a little
bit easier
i suppose um
aaron mcnally has a question about
stoicism what do you consider to be
essential stoicism
what text must one really know well um
if it's so you know there's the big
three right so we've got seneca who
wrote quite
a few things including the the letters
sometimes translated moral letters
letters to achilles uh letters on ethics
they're all the same thing
and then he's got all these treatises
like you know on anger
on constancy you know different
consolations so
we've got a lot of seneca stuff and then
there's epictetus the
discourses and the end caribbean and
then we've got marcus aurelius's
meditations
and i would say them you know seneca and
epictetus are more important than marcus
aurelius for understanding stoicism
um that's just the way it is marcus is
writing to himself
it's much less systematic it's great
stuff
but you know it's it's uh it's not it
shouldn't be like
the go-to which unfortunately it is for
a lot of you know
modern stoics um i would say you
definitely want to also read
the lectures that we have by musonius
rufus
and you want to read uh arius didymus's
epitome of stoic ethics
probably should read heroclies if you
can
if you get your hands on that and then
there's like texts by cicero
that our sister was not a stoic but the
stuff that he's giving you
on stoicism is the straight dope so you
know on
ends book three um stoic paradoxes
um on the nature of the gods book two um
on duties the entirety of it it's it's
essentially a stoic text through
filtered through
cicero and you know if you want to read
on divination you can
or the academics but you're not going to
get that much from it
and i would say that what makes a person
a modern stoic
is that they have gone past the i'm
going to read tim ferriss or ryan
holiday or whatever
which is fine as a starting point but
it's definitely
not enough and they've moved into
actual stoic texts and there's a
continual dialectic going back and forth
where they are not just practicing right
um they're they're actually using this
as a philosophy as a way of life to
restructure their life to
to use their their faculty of choice to
fix their faculty of choice
and likewise you know the what we call
the original faculty or the ruling
faculty
all those are by the way the same thing
so
that's that's what i would say um
a problem question here do i have a take
on brandon's interpretation of
or more generally a recent analytic
interest in hegel
so random is like um
in analytic philosophy would be like
kojev and continental philosophy
you're definitely getting something that
is connected to hegel
you're also getting something that's
definitely not straight hegel but
is that person's reinterpretation of it
um and it's a it's you know with both
coach evan brandum they're both smart
guys and have something to contribute
so they're worth reading just don't read
it as if that's
the straight hegel you know um
and you know the recent wave of analytic
interest in hegel
i wouldn't say there's a there's a wave
of it i would say there's a mild
interest in it i wouldn't even say
there's a wave of analytic interest
in nietzsche um you can i think you can
talk about a wave of interest in thomas
aquinas
largely driven by you know eleanor
stumpf
and and st louis university and all the
graduates that have come out of there
and it's usually not very good i mean
the more analytic it is
usually the less good it is in terms of
history of philosophy and engaging the
text
the more the brandom gets sort of an
honorary induction as a historian of
philosophy because he is coming out of
an analytic background but he leaves
behind a lot of limitations of analytic
philosophy
and in so doing effectively ceases to be
an analytic
so um that that's that's what i would
say um
all right uh
damn it says i was definitely one of
those thesis antithesis synthesis folks
for some reason i see everyone on
youtube talking about that exclusively
yeah i mean
that's the problem with with youtube is
it's um
people are there you know the people who
are doing the popular philosophy things
they are there to either and there will
be
some exceptions to this but they are
there to make money
establish themselves as as like a
celebrity
not an authority but a celebrity or
you know get as many subscribers as
possible and so you know putting and
putting out kind of you know
um crap content uh
that's that's uh kind of par for the
course
right um spookfester says youtube sends
you a giant metal play button at a
thousand
k subscriptions well that would be cool
i don't know what i would do with it
all right there's some back and forth
i'm gonna skip over here in terms of
like the
uh the um religious stuff i'm glad that
you're having a good conversation there
um
spookfest when i first read spirit i
assumed the third section
following the french revolution would be
about napoleon since i knew he loved
napoleon i struggled to read morality
because of that
um yeah you know i mean there's
there's not there's really no reference
to napoleon and
maybe it's the lord of the world you
know thing earlier on in the reason
section
um but there's really there's not a lot
of references to historical people in
general
in that right um aaron says what i love
about dr sandler is roughly
zero sentimentality for any idea or way
of thinking
yeah and that's that's something that
has happened over time
i i think i was a lot more sentimental
about ideas or ways of thinking in the
past but you know
what after a while that gets you kind of
worn off
gutter grown says he's partial to virtue
theory virtue theory is an abstraction
is not something i'm partial to because
that's all [ __ ] you know where
people are like
virtue theory is the idea that you know
then they have like a couple bullet
points
i'm partial to virtue theories in a
substantive sense so i
like plutarch as a representative you
know middle platonist i like
aristotle and alexander of aphrodisias
and alastair mcintyre in the present
as good representatives well and also
you know uh plenty
gisella striker and people like that i
like
uh stoicism as a virtue ethics but i
don't like virtue ethics in general i
think virtue ethics
done as an abstraction is just a silly
um uh
you know way of trying to like say oh
there's something beyond these other
these other things by the way i'll say
the same thing about utilitarianism
when people want to talk about
utilitarianism i want them to actually
like engage with bentham and mill and
preferably like sedgwick and singer
right
it's very important to do that
uh let's see
randall frody view on kierkegaard very
interesting guy uh
i like kierkegaard quite a bit i i don't
really
buy the oh it's it's you know all about
the leap of faith kind of thing because
there's so much else going on in his
work
uh pagan tribe and i had done any videos
on philip mainlander you can always find
what
videos i've done easily by just using
the search function if i haven't if you
don't find anything in search
i haven't done any videos on that that
guy right um
tony says thank you dr sadler the half
our hegel series has been
and continues to be a huge help in my
hegel class well that's that's good to
know
right um so long as your professor
doesn't get mad at you for using it
uh magnus what is the philosophical
motive of this book in this section what
why it is written what it is about well
i talked a little bit about that at the
start of this
um hegel theme seems to think that
religion is is something
you know very important for human beings
and that
it brings together all these other
aspects
it's not as good as philosophy but it's
certainly like on the way to philosophy
right um
agnostic monkey what's your opinion on
the projection theory of property rights
a hegel promoted
hagel promoted that i don't know what
the projection theory of property rights
is
uh caring love faith french is a
difficult language
i would love to learn one day it is a
difficult language
in part because like in english the
spelling
doesn't tell you how things actually
sound most of the time
and there are some like tone there's
some some phonemes in it
that are hard for a lot of people like
you know when i was talking about living
in the french house so we had this
this woman uh cecile revolte soul who
lived there who was from toulouse
and she would you know make us pronounce
difficult to pronounce words for english
speakers like
you know squirrel and some of the other
students just could not
wrap their their palette or tongue
around it
um i mean there is an advantage to
have a french speaking mom right um
and you know the the tense structure of
it is kind of screwy there's literary
tenses that nobody uses
anymore but were used at one time
yeah i mean the the good thing is is the
vocabulary isn't that big i think
the the lexicon of french is like
one-sixth the size of english
because english has somebody learn loan
words i think english is harder to learn
than french
but yeah gutter grown how long does it
take to get a basic grasp of the
language how many hours a week
i i don't know i imagine that probably
varies from person to person right
um all right
a lot of back and forth here uh
somebody who it just skipped over said
that they were a [ __ ] too
um uh callum o'connor i'm a massive
[ __ ]
sean smith philip k dick do you think if
an ai demonstrates altruism it would be
logic to consider it sentient
sure yeah i mean dickwood that was one
of the problems with the replicants
in um the android's dream of electric
sheep right they don't
have empathy for other
other beings i mean they could
demonstrate altruism without
empathy though but empathy
is really a key thing for philip k dick
uh lauren says i just wanted to say
excuse me i found your channel recently
and i love it
thanks for the huge amount of high
quality content i'm glad that you enjoy
it
and i'm you know i'm really fortunate in
that
i was sort of like in the right place at
the right time
to you know have developed um the
repertoire
that i had over the years which is not
because i
i was you know doing all the right
things you know like i said when i was a
graduate student i was you know
screwing around a lot drinking
exercising a ton
you know like three hours a day
sometimes uh that was part of that whole
nichian kick
but i managed to learn a lot in the
process in part because of the way the
curriculum was structured with the
very difficult prelims uh with massive
reading lists and stuff like that and
then i was able to you know be
established and i'll mention another
thing
my wife who's just below actually
listening to a seminar on heidegger
um she was one of the main impetuses for
me to put stuff
on youtube in the first place because um
she's an early adopter of technology and
was very much
sort of like a cheerleader you know uh
for giving giving things a try and i
you know said well who's going to watch
this i mean i'm a nobody
i teach at at that time some poor
historically black university
um i don't have a lot of i mean people
know my work on
ann salmon hobbs but that's about it and
that's in some very narrow circles
um who's actually gonna watch this and
she said just put it out there just try
it out and so i did and it was kind of a
good feedback loop people
found it useful and and i i just kept at
it you know and so
if if i had been i don't know maybe 10
years more long in my career
or you know wasn't with my at that time
fiance now wife
maybe i wouldn't have done it you know
all right um florida says
am i familiar with gg's interpretation
of hegel if you are what's your thoughts
on it so gj could be somebody sort of
like again kojova brandon
um it is definitely an interpretation
it's not it's not
like what i'm trying to do in the
commentary video sticking very closely
to the text or what ipolit
morales tried to do i'd say stanley
rosen kind of did in his own time as
well
um you know you're getting more g-jack
than you're getting
um getting uh uh
hegel but you know if you like zizek
then that's that's nice for you
unmasked hamburglar hegelian dialectics
and delusion idea of multiplicity
rhizomes mutually excluding
only if you make them so um
i mean you could think of it as sort of
like to lose is is uh
not just rejecting hagel but also
working within this
this hegel influenced background
slash system and and doing his own thing
right um
tony here's a good question about
especially in terms of the religion
stuff
what do you think about kierkegaard's
understanding and treatment of hegel
um also i found a website that sells
stoic hoodies because nothing says stoic
like a hoodie
yeah all that so i'm going to talk about
the second thing first if you're really
a stoic you don't you don't buy
any any stoic paraphernalia you don't
buy challenge coins
you don't like buy a bumper sticker you
definitely
don't need to get a tattoo to show
everybody how you're stoic
if you know it's really anti-stoic it
goes against
the view i mean if you say oh well i put
memento mori on my wrist
to remind me to do that seneca would say
jeez you dummy why did you put it on
there
why don't you put it in here you know
you're just showing off right
so there's there's a lot of that but
there's a lot of that for for everything
right
um i mean look at me i'm wearing my kiss
army t-shirt right now you know um
because uh because i like kiss i don't
like gene simmons so much
but you know i like the band um
stoicism shouldn't be reduced to that it
is you know
because uh anything that actually tends
to be popular i mean think about just
yoga right you know
if somebody tells me they practice yoga
i'm always like hey so what do you think
of uh the yoga sutras you know how
you're eating pot and jolly and they're
like pot and what then i'm like
you're not doing yoga then i guess you
know um
but you know there's all this this sort
of stuff going on
now kierkegaard is understanding uh and
treatment of hegel
there's two things to say um
kierkegaard understands hegel and
he is not actually targeting hegel as
such all the time he's more targeting
hegelians particularly the hegelians in
denmark
and in in germany where he studied
um and a lot of those are you know
sort of like you know they learn the
hegelian schtick and they do the stuff
he is very worried about hegel's
so we talked about this earlier right
there's religion and then there's
philosophy and religion is kind of a
preparation for philosophy
um kierkegaard is perfectly willing to
say that
yeah like what most people call religion
which isn't really religion at all is
is you know something that's that's
lower than philosophy
genuine faith maybe not you know
i mean if kierkegaard were around today
and looked at most people who call
themselves christians
he like i would say well actually a lot
of you are actually anti-antichrists
you're not you're not remotely christian
and you're just you know doing things to
get something out of it i mean i always
you know when somebody wants to like
throw bible verses at me
first thing i always do is say so how
are you living out the sermon on the
mount
how's that going for you and if they
they don't have a response well you know
they're full of crap
you know or or struggling right and they
they wound up with a bad bunch
you know in their church um if they're
always like talking about
you know culture war stuff but they're
not actually showing charity to their
neighbor
you know they're not a real christian
and and kierkegaard writes about a lot
of this
this kind of stuff right so i think i
think he's pretty good on that
um does he does he know everything no
but but he's good um
all right uh damon says uh did rousseau
hate civilization or just paris
both you know so it wasn't just paris
it's not the only place where you have
civilization um
let's see here all right i'm getting a
little bit
late so i'm going to scroll down a bit a
lot of these are people who have posted
stuff before
um galen says you once made a video on
the top 10 philosophical works you'd
bring to a desert island i would watch
another series you did on any one of the
other
nine you mean like a half hour series
yeah i mean again
i mentioned this at the top of the the
thing i'm gonna see what
what i'll do and what i'm actually
capable of doing
when i get to that that point um i also
hope that other people will
take up the methodology and do books
that that i don't do
oh stacy says happy chinese new year
along with hegel celebration is it
chinese new year or gong shifatsai you
know
i'm glad to to hear it um
that's that's uh i need to check my to
check the internet about
what the date is you know um
ayla on any discussions between judaism
and hegel's thought yeah
fackenheim who i mentioned earlier but
hegel is going to talk about judaism
in there a bit in that section um
a lot of back and forth here um
joey says just hopping on great to see
you doing going strong glad to see you
doing content on hegel
thanks yeah yeah um
tyson says what's the reason for the
rejection of hegel and analytic
philosophy
is that due to russell and moore and the
early british hegelians
um yeah so early on the rejection
is about rejecting not not just
hegel really but you know bradley and
greene and all those people
um later analytic philosophers just
don't read hegel
and don't read really anybody that's not
within their their sphere with some
exceptions like john wisdom
you know who's a great uh analytic
philosopher who reads all sorts of
people
but he's he's the the well and alistair
mcintyre who obviously quits being an
analytic at a certain point um
those are the exceptions to the rule and
at a certain point there's this like
open contempt
for anything that's not within their
sphere and we're talking several
generations after russell and moore
i remember actually having a professor
who
openly in siu and she was not an
analytic but she was a purse scholar you
know we're
we're carry we were talking about the
hegel reading group and she like looked
over and
unironically said why would anyone want
to read hegel and at that point my like
uh already shaky uh uh
you know esteem for her dropped
completely i was like
why would you say that about anybody
who's a great philosopher
there's just a lot of like oh that's you
know i already know about that stuff i'm
never going to try it out
which is sort of like people who say
that they they're no good at math or
they they
know they can't dance or stuff like that
they never try it out right
so yeah um
all right let's see what else i can take
and then kind of
wrap this up um
[Music]
uh yeah stacy says you tried at a
historically black university at
fayetteville state second oldest
university in the north carolina system
and constantly treated like crap because
the republicans run
north carolina through gerrymandering
and you know
voter suppression and stuff like that
yeah it was it was quite
interesting to work there um
spook fester do you have many students
studying hegel
no because i'm not i'm not actually
teaching hegel on any of the classes
that i'm doing now i have taught hegel
in the past
and um you know the biggest thing to
struggle with is like figuring out
what the hell is this crap right because
of the writing right
um
all right
[Music]
well guys are you thinking of writing a
lexicon book for the phenomenology of
spirit
i am definitely not um there's plenty of
people out there who've
done all sorts of great you know book
commentaries on
on the work there's no reason for me to
to do it particularly not being a
not hegel not being the center of my my
research
now it's interesting that you bring up
this idea of a lexicon book because
someday down the line i would like to do
a book that
is a lexicon of the philosophical
religious and psychological terminology
in philip k dick's novels and short
stories
that i think would actually be worth my
doing right
oh here's a good thing from lisa people
who want to learn a language check with
your public library to see if you have
access to canopy they have great courses
available
there are several languages there are
all sorts of platforms and apps and you
usually can get them through your local
library and you can usually do it online
but that's an excellent way to do it
when i was trying to work on some of my
languages
back then it was uh tapes that you would
get from the library
and you know you'd i'd do it while i was
working out like i'd put you know
weights in my backpack and go take a
five mile walk around milwaukee
listening to
somebody chatting german in my ears yeah
uh steven what do you think about
crowley and his philosophy religion of
thelama i've never taken him seriously
at all
and and i've had a few people who really
really were interested in turning me on
to it and it never turned
more back and forth stuff um
grass uh congrats i always refer to half
our hagel as an example for the web as a
learning source
do the files stay on youtube for late
comers and slow learners
um yeah obviously they're they're there
you just have to there's a
whole playlist on them um why wouldn't
they stay on youtube
it's not as if they go away after a
month or something they're they're all
out there
now if youtube ever goes down um well
then that's that's a problem and i do
need to start i think downloading the
older videos i've got
i was actually going to pick it up and
point but i don't want to take the
chance of unplugging it
i've got a you know big hard drive here
that has all of my videos from about
like 2016 16
2015 on them um i probably should go
back in time and download all that
content so it's available
in more than one place but yeah it's all
it's all there
um let's see here
elijah in light of the work of bart
ehrman do you think of the gospels of
john and matthew to be at least
representative what christianity should
be today what it should have become
so the work of bart airman i would say
there's like a great bart airman period
and then there's a like slide into
garbage scholarship period
that begins with his stuff on the gospel
of judas where
at that point i was like jesus i can't
take this guy seriously anymore
how the mighty have fallen
i don't see why the work of bart airman
should make me
think of the gospels of john and matthew
in any different way
any more than the many other biblical
scholars that are that are out there
that are
less adept at getting themselves into
the public spotlight
so um yeah but the guy i mean
let's say that we got rid of all these
these gospel scholars
um john and matthew and luke and mark
are normative for a christian thought
and
it's been that way for you know
two millennia um i i don't know how
like adding one more biblical critic to
the mix
changes anything so
um this is funny
every time that somebody writes dick
it's like flagging it and so i have to
um i have to click to
let it be there all right uh let's see
here
creates why is uh miguel de montaigne
not mentioned on philosophy much
same reason like 99 of philosophers are
not mentioned
on philosophy much
diligent escape matthew and luke were
thought to have been q-sourced
i don't care i mean when i taught
religious studies classes i read that it
doesn't matter that they were sourced
you look at what their role was within
the church
and what the content is you know people
are always all about source source
source you know
um let's see
i think i'm going to scroll up very
quickly see if there's anything
that i particularly miss there's a lot
of back and forth discussions
here's a good one to go out on what do i
think of gk
chesterton i enjoy his fiction quite a
lot
i think as an essayist he's a little bit
given to
you know like well here's a paradox you
know kind of
kind of thing but i enjoy him quite a
bit um i i
often don't enjoy chestertonians quite
as much
because they usually tend to be you know
catholic culture warriors
and into all sorts of other things that
chesterton and the
if he was brought to the president would
be like well that's [ __ ] you know
um but i like chesterton i actually did
a
um i devoted one of the worlds of
speculative fiction
series um lectures to chesterton
was i think that was in the second or
third year of the series you can go to
that playlist and find it
so i'm going to close here thanks for
all of the
comments and questions um glad all of
you could join me here for this
celebrating crossing a an important
passage
the last thing that i'll mention and i
should have mentioned it in the ama
yesterday and my wife reminded me um
uh during it but but i forgot to do it
is we've got a cool online event
happening here in milwaukee but
obviously it's online so it's available
for the entire world
and it's in eventbrite you can easily
find it it's using
aristotle's theory of friendship to
understand relationships we're doing
kind of a valentine's day
themed event and
we're it's also in my facebook page i'm
going to be putting it on the reason i
owe
calendar uh shortly with the the
eventbrite
page so if you want to do that that's
fine um you know
it's a sort of a repeat of something
that i've done
in the past but sort of updating it
for the present particularly thinking
about covent times
where relationships are often mediated
right through
digital means and so it's it should be a
fun workshop
to do so if you're interested in that
that's easy enough to find
on on the web
and uh yeah glad all of you could uh
join me here and i'll see you uh
that's either that online event or one
of the other online events or one of the
amas or political discussions
and hopefully we'll have another hegel
celebration before
too long because we'll get to the end of
the religion section and into
absolute knowing but i think that's
going to be a while from now we'll
probably hit the
100 000 subscribers before that